[Music]
today was the day that it became very
clear the Fed will do whatever it can to
keep the economy in the markets
functioning the Fed rolled out two new
lending facilities for the first time
lending directly to big US companies and
it also brought back some facilities we
haven't seen since 2008 so when the Fed
wants in a pinch like this to get money
out into the economy it starts by buying
the safest assets out there buys its own
debt back US Treasury bonds so they
started last week buying Treasury
another government debt and then on
Friday they said they would start by a
municipal bond and what you're starting
to see now is that that's not enough so
the Fed is going really a step down to
slightly more risky assets which is
corporate debt though they're gonna buy
corporate bonds it's gonna ship
corporate loans and that's a really
unprecedented step the markets did not
respond well at all the Dow and the SP
stock indexes end-of-the-day down about
three percent
they're now off 30 percent or so from
from their highs just a month or two ago
the market had its best day since 1933
today and that was due to lawmakers
getting close to signing a massive
stimulus bill to help the economy the
Dow finished up 11% today and the S&P
500 added nine point four percent which
marked its best days since 2008 markets
have actually been very volatile the
last couple of weeks and it's not been
unusual to see these really big down
days followed immediately after by
really big up days for instance even
though we had the biggest gain for the
Dow since 1933 today we've also within
the last couple of weeks seen some of
the stock market's worst Falls in
history on March 9th March 12 and March
16th
once there was another really volatile
day in the stock market the S&P 500 rose
as much as 5% in the afternoon before
ending the day up 1.2 percent so is
another crazy day for investors and all
of us financial journalists watching at
home stocks closed positive for two days
in a row that's the first time that's
happened since February 12 Wednesday's
moves came with traders and investors
really trekking on Congress every five
minutes or so to see where the economic
stimulus package stands so markets rose
a lot on anticipation that it would pass
and they paired some of the gains on
signs that maybe it won't be as smooth
one of the most fascinating things about
Wednesday's moves was the massive slings
and airline stocks and Boeing Boeing
which is a big component of the Dow rose
24% and that's the positive side for
some people who track short-term gains
but bigger picture some investors are
still really worried about the intraday
swings and how big they are we're also
waiting to see again hard economic data
what's been really crazy is how fast
this has all happened in only a few
weeks we actually haven't seen much hard
data yet showing the really big slowdown
we're all preparing for as those data
points start coming in whether they're
worse than expected or somewhat work
better than feared things like that
could really shape how markets swing
over the coming days and then the next
week - today we saw that jobless claims
hit a record high the number of people
applying for unemployment benefits hit a
record 3.3 million so that's a sign of
how this coronavirus is taking a toll on
on humans and the economy it's really
hard to overstate how bad this number
was you know this was above the numbers
that we saw during the global financial
crisis and it's nearly five times the
previous high that we've ever
so there's this huge disconnect out
there you've got these really really
dark figures on jobless claims the worst
that we've ever seen and on the other
hand you have stocks soaring they just
ripped higher the Dow Jones Industrial
Average was up six percent and it just
logged its best in three days streak
since the 1930s some people think that
we can actually have a pretty speedy
recovery in the third and fourth
quarters of this year and other people
think that hey we don't know we could be
in for prolonged downturn so stocks
ended Friday down but three days of
gains despite you know some pretty
encouraging signs out of Washington
where the big coronavirus eight bill did
get passed and signed by the president
so stocks had a tough day that said
there were some more encouraging signs
out of the credit markets in particular
demand for this emergency funding that
the Federal Reserve has been providing
overnight dramatically fell it's this
very crucial part of the funding markets
and it literally keeps lights on
overnight at banks and companies you
know all around America two weeks ago
when the Fed rolled out its repo
facility it had more than 250 billion
dollars of demand people in the market
saying I knew cash today had only just a
little bit above 10 billion and so that
tells you that the private market is
starting to do its job again and maybe
the Fed isn't needed quite so much there
one thing that's important to remember
is this is at the end of the day a
health crisis and the bill that comes
through Congress certainly has has about
a hundred and fifty billion dollars for
hospitals it has aid for municipalities
but it can't it can't fight the virus on
its own and so markets are still gonna
be pretty pretty concerned until there's
better data on the coronavirus front